peter schiff the ultimate bitcoin bear
he's having a lot of problems with his
fiat bank down in puerto rico and all of
a sudden he seems to be a lot more
sympathetic to the bitcoin story as many
people know peter schiff's bank is being
shut down by regulators for a lot of
different issues and he recently was
asked on twitter would he sell the bank
for bitcoin and peter jumped right in
and he said actually yes i'd sell the
bank for anything regulators let me sell
it my main goal is protecting customers
now i'm not an expert on all of the
different details of what's going on
with this fiat bank but what i do know
is that peter schiff is getting a crash
course in how important bitcoin and the
idea of self-sovereignty can be
bitcoin as a decentralized digital
currency allows anyone in the world to
hold their private keys not your keys
not your coins and of course in the fiat
banking system that isn't possible
if you put your money into a bank it is
now the bank's money and they simply
give you an iou
bitcoin is a superior technology it
offloads all of that risk from your
counterparty and it says you now are in
control peter schiff and his fiat bank
they're getting that crash course right
now
my guess is even though peter schiff's
entire reputation has been built around
being the bitcoin bear this moment in
history is likely going to make him much
much more enthusiastic about bitcoin i
don't know if he'll flip and become a
bull but what i do know is that peter
schiff now understands why bitcoin is so
important to billions of people around
the world